we are told the triangle n prime is the
image of triangle n under a dilation so
this is n prime and in this red color
and then n is the original and is in
this blue color what is the center of
dilation and they give us some choices
here choice a B C or D as a center of
dilation so pause this video and see if
you can figure it out on your own so
there's a couple of ways to think about
it one way I like to just first think
about what is the what is the scale
factor here so in our original n we have
this side here it has a length of 2 and
then once we dilated it by and use that
scale factor that corresponding side has
a length of 4 so we went from 2 to 4 so
we can figure out our scale factor scale
factor is equal to 2 2 times 2 is equal
to 4 now what about our center of
dilation so one way to think about it is
pick two corresponding points so let's
say we were to pick this point and this
point so the image the corresponding
point on n prime is going to be the
scale factor as far away from our center
of dilation as the original point so in
this example we know the scale factor is
2 so this is going to be twice as far
from our center of dilation as the
corresponding point well you can
immediately see and it's going to be in
the same direction so actually a little
bit if you just draw a line connecting
these two there's actually only one
choice that sits on that line and that
is choice D right over here as being the
center of dilation and you can also
verify that notice this first point on
the original triangle it's change in X
is 2 and it's change in Y is 3 to 3 to
go from point D to point to that point
and then if you want to go to point D to
its image
well now you got to go twice as far your
change in X is 4 and your change in Y is
6 you could use the Pythagorean theorem
to calculate this distance and then the
longer distance
but what you see is is that the
corresponding point is now twice as far
from your center of dilation so there's
a couple of ways to think about it one
if you connect corresponding points your
center of dilation is going to be on a
line that connects those two points and
that the image should be the scale
factor as far away from the center of
dilation in this case it should be twice
as far from the center of dilation as
the point that it is the image of